se conoce como el complot de la tarta de
cerdo ya que docenas de sus propios
diputados amenazan con desencadenar una
moción de censura contra el primer
ministro británico tras las fiestas
celebradas en downing street durante el
confinamiento se dice que un grupo de
conservadores se reunió para discutir
cómo destituir a boris johnson mientras
que varios diputados aseguraron haber
presentado cartas de desconfianza contra
su líder harían falta 54 para abrir un
concurso de liderazgo un revuelo que
llega tras una polémica entrevista de
johnson en la que negó haber mentido al
parlamento y aseguró creer que las
reuniones no infringían las normas de
cierre nadie me advirtió de que fuera
contra las normas soy absolutamente
categórico al respecto porque lo
recordaría el primer ministro se negó a
descartar la posibilidad de dimitir y se
refirió en varias ocasiones a la
investigación interna que se está
llevando a cabo para esclarecer los
hechos está previsto que el informe se
publique a finales de mes a pesar de la
indignación de la opinión pública
algunos ministros del gabinete siguen
apoyando le seguir crees que dice la
verdad por supuesto que si sube y está
llevando a cabo una investigación sobre
la situación creo que es correcto que le
permitamos concluir ese trabajo
y usted apoya al primer ministro
incondicionalmente fuego
en medio de la crisis política reino
unido- plantea levantar las
restricciones contra el hobbit 19 este
miércoles una medida que sus oponentes
describen como un intento por distraer
sobre el llamado par y kate varios
informes afirman que johnson espera que
una serie de anuncios políticos ayuden a
limpiar su imagen entre ellos la
congelación del canon de la bbc- y los
planes de utilizar al ejército para
evitar la llegada de emigrantes